busque la masa de una pelota de tenis y
resulta que una pelota de tenis tiene
una masa de 58 gramos o de punto 0 58
kilogramos y yo me pregunto si lanzamos
esta pelota de tenis hacia la derecha
directo hacia esta pelota de golf y
busco la masa de esta pelota de golf me
encuentro que es de casi 45 gramos o
puntos 0 45 kilogramos así que si
lanzamos estas pelotas hacia ellas con
cierta rapidez digamos que la pelota de
golf se está moviendo a 50 metros por
segundo y la pelota de tenis se está
moviendo a 40 metros por segundo ambas
pelotas van a chocar directamente entre
sí las vamos a lanzar de manera que
mantenga en esta dirección
no quiero que por ejemplo esta pelota de
golf se desvíe hacia acá así que todo va
a ocurrir en una dimensión mi pregunta
es si solo nos dan las velocidades
iniciales y las masas podremos encontrar
las velocidades finales de la pelota de
tenis y la pelota de golf vamos a
intentarlo por donde comenzamos cuando
resolvemos un problema de colisión
normal
comenzamos con la conservación del
momento yo sé que si es una colisión
rápida el momento justo antes de que
ocurra la colisión va a ser igual al
momento justo después de la colisión al
menos con respecto a las cantidades
totales porque se cumple esto al menos
por ejemplo para esta pelota de golf
justo en el instante en el que está en
contacto con la pelota de tenis va a ser
tan pequeño que cualquier fuerza externa
no va a tener oportunidad de actuar
fuerzas externas como la gravedad no van
a tener el tiempo suficiente de afectar
o de agregarle un impulso extra a este
sistema y si no tengo un impulso externo
entonces el momento total justo antes de
la colisión va a ser igual al momento
total justo después de la colisión el
momento total de nuestro sistema de la
pelota de tenis y la pelota de golf se
va a mantener constante y esto se cumple
básicamente para cualquier colisión
entre dos objetos que se mueven
libremente así que podemos suponer que
el momento total se va a conservar qué
significa esto matemáticamente tengo
en el momento que estoy representando
con la letra p p y es el momento inicial
y además voy a agregar sigma porque
estoy hablando del momento total inicial
no es el momento de un solo objeto sino
el momento de todos los objetos
involucrados y además voy a poner un
símbolo de vector aquí arriba ya que el
momento es un vector lo cual es
importante ya que el momento puede ser
negativo y no podemos olvidar los signos
negativos aquí y si se conserva el
momento entonces este momento inicial
total debe ser igual al momento total
final esto es a lo que nos referimos
cuando decimos que se conserva el
momento total recuerden que la fórmula
para el momento es masa por velocidad
así que el momento inicial de la pelota
de tenis va a ser masa por velocidad es
decir 0.58 kilogramos por su velocidad
inicial que es de 40 metros por segundo
y como va hacia la derecha va a ser
positiva el momento inicial de la pelota
de tenis también va a ser masa por
velocidad
0.0 45 kilogramos
su velocidad inicial que es de 50 metros
por segundo a la izquierda la voy a
poner con signo negativo ya que esto me
indica la dirección normalmente
suponemos que la dirección a la derecha
es positiva y la dirección a la
izquierda es negativa así pues todo esto
es el momento inicial total y como el
momento total se conserva esto debe ser
igual al momento total final el momento
final de la pelota de tenis ese 0 punto
0 58 kilogramos por su velocidad final
que no sabemos y esta incógnita le voy a
llamar vete te de tenis más el momento
final de la pelota de golf + 0 puntos 0
45 kilogramos por su velocidad final que
también desconozco entonces a esta
incógnita le voy a llamar eje de mi
pelota de golf esta va a ser su
velocidad después de la colisión y ahora
puedo encontrar los valores de la
velocidad final de la pelota de tenis y
la velocidad final de la pelota de golf
pues no no puedo porque tengo una
ecuación y dos incógnitas en otras
palabras puedo calcular el valor de este
lado izquierdo de la ecuación todo esto
me queda 0.07 kilogramos metros por
segundo como el momento total inicial
pero esto va a ser igual a dos
incógnitas entonces necesito un pedazo
más de información para poder resolver
esto por ejemplo si yo conociera alguna
de estas velocidades finales
desconocidas podría fácilmente encontrar
la segunda por ejemplo si el problema me
diera como dato la velocidad final de la
pelota de tenis pues yo podría encontrar
sin ningún problema el valor final de la
pelota de golf o quizá el problema
podría decirnos qué tipo de colisión es
si nos dijera que estos dos objetos se
quedan pegados yo podría saber que se
mueven juntos la cual sería una colisión
perfectamente inelástica y si este fuera
el caso yo aquí tendría una gran masa
total la masa de la pelota de tenis más
la masa de la pelota de golf esto sería
una gran masa ya que ambos quedarían
juntos si tuviéramos una colisión
perfectamente inelástica y esto sería
multiplicado
a una sola velocidad final ya que ambos
estarían moviendo a la misma velocidad
tomaría este 0.07 y lo dividiría entre
la masa total y encontraría la velocidad
final total y encontraría la velocidad
final de ambas pelotas combinadas pero
esto es muy poco probable estas pelotas
no van a permanecer juntas no se
juntarán la pelota de tenis ni la pelota
de golf a menos que aquí tuviéramos
algún tipo de pegamento de otra forma no
creo que estas puedan permanecer juntas
así que vamos a suponer que esto no
ocurre sin embargo si nos dijeran que
estas dos masas se quedan juntas después
de la colisión de esta forma podríamos
resolver el problema pero en este caso
con la pelota de tenis y la pelota de
golf es más probable que sea una
colisión elástica y recuerden que
elástico significa que la energía
cinética total en esta colisión va a
permanecer constante o se va a conservar
es decir no vamos a perder energía
cinética
vamos a perder ni en energía térmica ni
en sonido y resulta que si nos dijeran
que esta es una colisión elástica sería
suficiente para poder encontrar estas
dos incógnitas y la razón es que esto
implica que se conserva la energía
cinética y podemos usar esto para
nuestra ventaja ya que no sólo sabemos
que se está conservando el momento sino
que si la colisión es elástica también
se va a conservar la energía cinética
así que la energía cinética total
inicial tiene que ser igual a la energía
cinética total final y recuerden que la
energía cinética es igual a un medio de
la masa por la velocidad al cuadrado así
que puedo decir que un medio de 0.58
kilogramos por 40 metros por segundo al
cuadrado esto es la masa y velocidad
inicial de la pelota de tenis y aquí
nunca olvidemos que es al cuadrado a
esto le sumó la energía cinética inicial
de la pelota de golf es un medio por
0.45 kilogramos que es la masa de esta
pelota de golf por su velocidad inicial
que es de 50 metros por segundo
lo elevamos al cuadrado y esta cantidad
la pongo positiva porque de todas
maneras la voy a elevar al cuadrado
esta es la rapidez de la energía
cinética aquí no importa la dirección
aunque en el momento si importa ya que
aquí estamos hablando de vectores pero
con la energía cinética como lo estamos
elevando al cuadrado y de por sí el
energía cinética es un escalar no puede
ser negativa y no va a importar si
usamos el signo aquí o no se va a
eliminar cuando elevemos esto al
cuadrado y esta energía cinética total
inicial debe ser igual a la energía
cinética total final por lo que puedo
decir que toda esta cantidad inicial
debe ser igual a la energía cinética
final de la pelota de tenis que es un
medio por 0 punto 0 58 kilogramos por la
velocidad final de esta pelota al
cuadrado a esto le agregamos la energía
cinética final de la pelota de golf que
es de un medio por cero punto 0 45
kilogramos
de g al cuadrado y ustedes me pueden
decir a ver cómo es que esto me va a
ayudar ahora tenemos estas variables al
cuadrado esto luce horrible pero ahora
créanme que si podemos resolver esto
pues tenemos dos ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas y estas dos incógnitas aquí
son las mismas que estas dos incógnitas
de acá cuando tenemos esto despejamos la
incógnita en una de las ecuaciones y las
sustituimos en la otra ecuación y así
nos quedara una ecuación con una
incógnita
en otras palabras déjenme mostrarles
esto vamos a calcular este lado derecho
es el lado izquierdo que se que está
aquí arriba y me queda 102 puntos 65
jules de energía cinética inicial total
pero seguimos teniendo estas dos
incógnitas en esta ecuación ahora me
paso a esta ecuación acá y voy a
despejar bg si despejo vejez voy a
restar 0 punto 0 58 vete en ambos lados
de la igualdad y esto va a ser igual a
cero punto 0 45 mg dividido a ambos
lados en 30 puntos 0 45 y me queda 0.07
en 30 puntos 0 45 es 1.56 y aquí punto 0
58 entre punto 0 45 es menos 1 punto
29 esto está multiplicado por 20 y esto
es igual a bg y mi velocidad final de la
pelota de golf es igual a esta expresión
de aquí tomamos esta expresión que es
igual a bg y la vamos a sustituir en la
otra ecuación lo que me da un medio de
0.0 45 kilogramos por 1.56 menos 1.29
vete todo esto al cuadrado ya que
tenemos esta vejez al cuadrado solamente
estamos sustituyendo esta expresión de
vejez aquí en esta vejez al cuadrado que
aún tenemos que multiplicar por este un
medio y este punto 0 45 y además tenemos
toda esta otra parte tenemos 102 puntos
65 jules y
y un medio por punto 0 58 kilogramos
vete al cuadrado más esta expresión de
aquí y sería un poco desordenado pero
ahora ya tengo una ecuación con una sola
incógnita ya que aquí solamente tenemos
vete haciendo los cálculos nos queda que
102 puntos 65 jules es igual a punto 0
58 entre 2 es cero puntos 0 29 vete al
cuadrado no voy a estar poniendo las
unidades porque se me va a complicar un
poco más escribirlo y si dividido 0.0 45
entre 2 me queda punto 0 225 y ahora
tengo que elevar al cuadrado esta
expresión y si ustedes recuerdan cuando
tienen una expresión de a menos b al
cuadrado nos queda al cuadrado que es
1.56 al cuadrado menos 2 por a
a 1.56 por b o la cantidad del segundo
término que es 1.29 y le sumamos el
segundo elemento al cuadrado que es 1.29
al cuadrado por la velocidad final de la
pelota de tenis al cuadrado lo que estoy
haciendo aquí es que si ustedes tienen a
menos b todo esto elevado al cuadrado
esto va a ser igual a al cuadrado menos
2 por a o por b más b al cuadrado esto
es lo que hicimos acá esta es mía y aquí
está mía al cuadrado y tenemos este
menos 2 por el primer término 1.56 pone
el segundo término que es 1.29 bt y al
final le sumamos b al cuadrado o 1.29 al
cuadrado por bt al cuadrado y ahora
tenemos un desastre vamos a tratar de
poner un poco de orden aquí el lado
izquierdo sigue siendo 102 puntos 65
jules y sigo teniendo este 0 puntos 0 29
vete al cuadrado pero ahora necesito
multiplicar este punto 0 225 por todo
esto de aquí diego esto me queda 0.05 48
que es la multiplicación de puntos 0 25
x 1.56 al cuadrado y ahora tengo menos
0.09 06 vete
qué es la multiplicación de puntos 025
por toda esta cantidad de aquí y
finalmente me queda punto cero 374 por
bt al cuadrado esto es la multiplicación
de puntos 0 25 por esta cantidad de acá
vamos a encontrar nuestras veces aquí
tengo una vete y aquí tengo una vete al
cuadrado así que puedo combinar este
término que tiene 20 al cuadrado con
este otro término que también tiene a
vete al cuadrado y me queda que es igual
a punto 0 66 vete al cuadrado menos
punto 0 906 vete más puntos 0 5 4 8 y
les prometo que ya nos estamos acercando
al final restamos este 102 puntos 65 de
ambos lados de la igualdad por lo que
nos da 0 igual a toda esta cantidad y
punto 0 5 48 menos 102 puntos 65 lo que
nos da menos 102 puntos 59 5 y esto que
tenemos aquí es la eco
cuadrática esto quiere decir que no
vamos a poder despejar la vete dejándola
en un solo lado nunca va a funcionar
aquí tenemos que usar la fórmula
cuadrática en nuestra fórmula cuadrática
este término de punto 066 va a ser a y
este menos punto 0 906 va a ser b y
finalmente este menos ciento 2.595 va a
hacerse y ustedes pueden calcular esto a
mano o usar una aplicación para resolver
ecuaciones cuadráticas estas
aplicaciones las pueden encontrar en
línea o incluso en su calculadora y es
lo que yo voy a hacer voy a usar la
aplicación de mi calculadora y las dos
respuestas que obtengo de esto es vete
igual a 40 metros por segundo como una
de las respuestas y obtengo menos 39
metros por segundo y cuál será la
correcta 40 o menos 39 podemos darnos
cuenta de cuál es la respuesta correcta
por ejemplo si vemos esta vez de igual a
40 pues es la velocidad inicial de esta
pelota es la velocidad que ya tenía
así que esta otra será la velocidad
final y cómo es que encontramos la
velocidad inicial aquí pues resulta que
una forma de conservar el momento y la
energía es que estos objetos no se
toquen para nada si la pelota de golf no
colisionará con la pelota de tenis
simplemente continuará con su
trayectoria ambas mantendrían su
velocidad inicial lo cual corresponde a
esto
esta es una colisión que no ocurre así
que sabemos que esta colisión no nos
interesa
estamos buscando esta velocidad de acá
después de la colisión esta pelota de
tenis va en sentido contrario con una
velocidad de menos 39 metros por segundo
y ahora como encontramos la velocidad de
la pelota de golf después de la colisión
pues ya que tengo la velocidad de la
pelota de tenis voy a sustituirla en
esta otra ecuación y así encontraré la
velocidad de la pelota de golf ahora mi
velocidad de la pelota de golf va a ser
1 punto 56 - 1.29 que multiplica a la
velocidad de la pelota de tenis
fue de -39 aquí tengo 52 metros por
segundo positivo
esta es la velocidad de la pelota de
golf después de la colisión lo que
quiere decir que esta pelota después de
la colisión fue hacia la derecha ya que
es una velocidad positiva y rebotó con
una velocidad de 52 metros por segundo
en resumen lo que hacemos cuando nos dan
las velocidades iniciales y las masas
tratamos de usar la conservación del
momento lo cual estuvo bien a excepción
de que nos quedamos con dos incógnitas
por lo que tuvimos que escribir otra
ecuación con estas dos incógnitas y
pudimos hacerlo ya que nos indicaron que
esta colisión es elástica por lo que
sabemos que la energía cinética total se
conserva escribimos esa ecuación y
también nos quedamos con dos incógnitas
así que despejamos la ecuación del
momento para una de las incógnitas y la
sustituimos en la otra ecuación la
reemplazamos en la vejez de esta
ecuación de la energía cinética la
elevamos al cuadrado y nos quedamos con
una ecuación y una
pero desafortunadamente nos dio una
ecuación cuadrática así que tuvimos que
usar la fórmula cuadrática para
resolverla y de los dos resultados uno
de ellos corresponde a la velocidad
inicial del objeto lo cual no es el dato
que nos interesa ya que significaría que
no ocurrió ninguna colisión tomamos el
segundo resultado y lo usamos para
encontrar la velocidad del otro objeto
este valor lo sustituimos en esta
expresión y así obtenemos la velocidad
final del otro objeto